in case you missed it Marines in one
piece have bounties now that's thanks to
mihawks and crocodile's newly formed
cross-skilled organization that pulled
the ultimate Uno reverse card and is now
putting money on the heads of Marines so
let's try and predict what the bouncy of
the top level Marines will be starting
with Luffy's grandfather vice admiral
Monkey D GARP known as the hero of the
Marines How much is he worth GARP is one
of the oldest still active Marines
however no one would make the mistake to
underestimate this man even now as
father of the world's most wanted
criminal Monkey D dragon and grandfather
of the current yonko and future pirate
king Monkey D Luffy it's no big surprise
that Garb used to be one of the
strongest Marines in history he and
Fleet Admiral zingoku were the faces of
the Marine forces during the legendary
era of the likes of Goldie Roger
Whitebeard and Roxy's back the only
reason that GARP state only advice
Admiral level was because he repeatedly
refused a promotion to either Admiral or
Fleet Admiral and that's because in
these positions you are basically at the
direct disposal of the celestial dragons
the corrupt ruling class of one piece
that GARP himself despises during his
prime GARP regularly clashed with the
strongest pirates in one piece history
and was respected by all of them not
only did he train Luffy as a kid but he
also trained the current generation of
Elite Marine Fighters such as aokiji and
even though GARP is serving in more of
an advisory position at this point we
can assume that he is still one of the
most powerful Marines in existence after
all during the ward Marine Ford sengoku
had to actually stop him from attacking
a kainu seemingly genuinely worried that
GARP would kill the strongest Admiral
after he killed his grandson Ace so
what's this man's Bounty going to be
like now we haven't actually seen any of
the Marine bounties officially yet so
there's nothing that we can anchor our
estimate to right now it seems that
instead of a number like in the pirate
bounties the Marine bounty Mounds are
indicated by these symbols and the ones
we've seen so far are either two stars
three stars or a crown now I would
assume that each symbol corresponds to
either a certain Marine rank or a
certain amount of money like a star is a
captain or a star is 100 million berries
we also have no idea how much money
crocodile and mihawk actually have to
finance all these Marine Bounties in the
first place it could be a lot less than
regular pirate bounties given that the
world government has massive Financial
Resources however we also know that the
cross Guild has a lot of backing from
the criminal underworld in one piece so
I think for the sake of this video Let's
just assume that buggy mihawk and
crocodile have a lot of free cash flow
that they have allocated to this project
and so I also want to assume that Marine
bounties and pirate bounties are on the
exact same level that makes them a lot
easier to deduce and compare as well for
GARP that means that as a legend of the
Marines who could fight with the likes
of Roger Whitebeard and rocks he would
absolutely be in the top tier of Marine
Bounty so if we compare him to the
bounties of all these Legends if I was
crocodile I think it would be fair to
give Garb a 3 billion very bouncy the
same as his grandson Luffy has currently
I think that reflects his power and
former glory but at the same time also
factors in that he has grown old and
only receives this first Bounty now at
78 years old and in terms of the Cross
Girl posters this could be three crowns
for instance one crown for each one
billion berries now in contrast to a
legend like Garb what would be the
Bounty of someone a lot lower like
Luffy's former Marine rival smoker the
reason I find him extremely interesting
as an example here is because smoker
went from a character far more powerful
than Luffy to the point where none of
the straw hats could actually touch him
to a marine that we all would see as
relatively weak especially after he got
completely humiliated by doflamingo on
hazards at some point Luffy and in fact
all of the straw hats really passed him
in power I would argue that this
happened during the time skip I mean
Luffy Zoro and Sanji you all learned
hockey and thus Smoker's big Advantage
his lokia fruit became pretty much
irrelevant and so even though smoker is
now a vice admiral just like GARP I
would give him a bounty of only 300
million berries same as Luffy after
defeating crocodile and a bit less than
current Nami which I do think is pretty
much the best that he could hope for so
let's compare that to the current three
Admirals kizaru fujitora and yokugyu are
the top three strongest fighters in the
Marines next to akinu right now now we
actually don't know if the Admirals
could actually physically match a yonko
in a one versus one but they are pretty
much the Marine equivalent to the
empress and therefore I do think they
should have a decently High Bounty
definitely in the billionberry range now
from mihawks and crocodile's perspective
the lowest Bounty I think should go to
green ball Not only was he not exactly
convincing during his appearance in wano
despite his incredibly awesome devil
fruit but crocodiles desert lokia powers
are pretty much green balls exact
weakness so overall he is probably the
Admiral that cross Guild needs to be the
least worried about since he is an
active Admiral though I would give him a
higher Bounty than GARP but a lower one
than let's say Blackbeard so 3.5 billion
berries seems like a pretty good number
here kizeru is a very different Beast
despite his apparently lazy attitude he
is always eager to face the strongest
opponents possible all on his own and
we've already seen multiple times just
how devastating and effective he can
truly be so 3.8 billion berries sounds
like a pretty good fit for him and so
now you might be surprised that fujitora
gets my highest Bounty out of all three
of the Admirals but remember that he was
the one who got rid of the warlord
system in the first place and
immediately started a hunt for crocodile
mihawk and code so out of all the
Marines for sure he will be the most
focused on this new group formed by
exclusively former Warlords and thus
poses the biggest threat for cross
skills so I would say if you take down
fujito you get 4 billion berries
alternatively if you subscribe to this
channel you get fresh high quality
one-piece contents every single week and
moving on to the only character that has
had an even more impressive glow up than
Luffy throughout one piece the very
first friend and fact that he makes in
the story Kobe now Kobe might not seem
like a major threat at first glance but
that's because you know him as a friend
and Ally of Luffy actually more fanboyed
than friend really but from an outsider
perspective Kobe Grew From a tiny 12
year old looking guy into a full-grown
man in just two years this man went from
sweeping decks to a full-blown Marine
captain in record time he's been
personally trained by Garth who as you
know trade the likes of aokiji he has
mass at hockey the techniques of the six
powers and is part of the secret Marine
organization swords on top of that
crocodile mihawk and buggy all three saw
Kobe standing up to a kainu during the
marineford war and they saw Shanks
protecting and they might also well know
that he is aiming to become an admiral
himself so I think it's more than
reasonable to give Kobe the hero a
bounty of at least 500 million berries
for his fast rise through the ranks his
body helmetbo meanwhile I would give 250
million maybe a bit less than smoker
next we have one of the most mysterious
characters in the series come in case
you don't know who that is it's because
there is barely anything that we know
about this character even though he is
technically the most important Marine in
one piece during garbs and sengoku's era
he was the previous Fleet Admiral which
is the highest rank in the Marines until
he got promoted to what you asked well
his current position is that of world
government Commander in Chief but simply
that means that the only people ranking
higher than Kong in the world are the
five elders and emu themselves Kong not
only has full control over the entire
Marine system but also commands the
government's secret agencies and as
Lobby and in pull down and even the
seven Warlords of the sea when they were
still a thing I guess sengoku had to
come to his office to offer his
resignation as Fleet Admiral and it was
technically also Kong who officially
decided that Akainu would be the new
Fleet Admiral as well and while zangoku
and Garb led the current generation of
top Marines Kong led the generation of
sengoku and GARP so we can only assume
how powerful he must be plus look at
this man's forearms and his face guard
and he has a monkey theme just like
Luffy so this dude knows how to fight
similar to GARP and sengoku he is quite
old but due to his strength and
especially his political position taking
him out would truly throw the entire
world government into complete chaos so
I do personally think that despite the
little that we know about him Kong
deserves the second highest Marine
bouncy of 4.5 billion berries because
the highest Marine bouncy will without
any doubt go to the scariest and as far
as we know currently strongest Marine in
one piece Fleet Admiral zakazuki
formerly known as Admiral akanu Akino
has been built up by Oda to be one of
the main villains of the story he's been
the reason for both Luffy's and Robin's
deepest and darkest moments he's the
Marine that goes hard against any pirate
with no mercy no matter the circumstance
and as we know he does have the power to
back that up as well as the current
Fleet Admiral he is the head of the
Marine forces and even though Kong is
above him in rank technically the story
suggests that currently there is no
Marine that is more powerful than him
and so as the biggest threat to cross
Guild and pirates in general if we're
being honest a kind of deserves the
highest Bounty out of all the Marines
I'm incredibly curious to find out how
the cross Guild bounty system actually
works and how much each Marine will be
worth but in the context of this video I
think Akino deserves a 4.8 billion very
Bounty and with that he would also make
it into the top 5 of the highest pirate
bounties as well if you want to know who
is above him and all remaining official
1 billion plus Berry bounties you can
watch that video right here